[Music]
so as I crashed into the cold dark water
of the Pacific I realized a few things
hey I have no idea where I'm going B
salt water stings C I shouldn't even be
on this planet right now but I am why
because you shot me I know you shot me
alright I heard you the first time you
don't have to pile it on good grief
I'm wet I'm cold there's a fish on my
head and clearly I'm not gonna be able
to do this on my own
alright get in the truck
really you're gonna help me I guess it
is a little bit my fault that all this
is happening to you not a little bit
entirely it is entirely your fault it's
entirely my fault or you come yes road
trip what am i doing the time for
talking is over it's time to push
buddies you're flying eggs are pretty
impressive mr. Eggman but let's face it
you'll never catch me hon fidence a
fool's substitute for intelligence
[Music]
that's not good Sonic you got the super
speed and everything but Maddie and I
totally defense this probably gonna get
blown up pretty much yeah
don't worry I know exactly what to do I
[Applause]
was not expecting that but I was
expecting not to expect something so it
doesn't count
[Music]
oh this one is cute let's keep
you got car insurance right
buzz off I doesn't sound good no peeking
is bad get rid of it I'm trying row it
up the wind boat anywhere I can't get it
alright I'm pulling over
[Applause]
can I get it
no air hostess it's going it's still
here
this is the island where I'm from it had
everything sandy beaches test gating
waterfalls public access to
loop-de-loops and I never had to catch a
school bus because I could run across
the entire island in less than two
seconds also there was no school I know
pretty sweet Island right
when it comes to speed there's only one
name I've studied the best spinners his
legendary I raced the fastest in the
world he makes us all its left I'm wild
but he's on another level that dude he
knows it's all about the Rings when he
turns on the burners good luck
he's just a blur out there what's this
for again what's this for again this
Morgan what's this for again great
question I have no idea but please
McCaffrey go on about how amazing I am
what am i doing
now that's what I call good cop bad cop
left yourself open I'm Sonic a little
ball of super energy in an extremely
handsome package on my planet people
were always after my powers so I came to
yours it gets a little lonely
okay I am living my best life butter the
place at the pitcher's mound also no I
can't with that guy
oh why are you hiding out in my garage
if they steal my power they can conquer
the universe you have to help me Louie
no please it's life or death
good morning my royal Chum mr. dr.
Robotnik I'm going to give you five
seconds to tell me where it is
[Applause]
[Music]
this can't be happening to me oh my god
all right what's the world's largest
rubber band ball we gotta see it no this
is not some fun family road trip you're
right it was lame gift shop let's go
though whatever this creature is I'm
going to uncover the source its power
[Music]
I just thought you might like a latte
with steamed Austrian goat milk of
course I would a lot of take I love the
way you make them we gotta lay low let
me show you how it's done so super get
out of here yeah time to go
that was an illegal left by the way why
would you throw your life away for this
citizen of alien your time is my friend
[Applause]
to protect my friends
so you're supposed to be Tom's best
friend that he won't shut up about well
I don't see the appeal
[Music]